- This is what I love about you.
Cause I actually,
in the beginning of my
career turned down deals
because it literally
was like selling my soul
if I signed the dotted
line, and I was like, look,
I'm a waitress and I don't have anything,
but you're not gonna hold
that over my head and take
everything from me.
I was like, and nobody understood that.
They always thought
that I was being a diva.
And like, you should just
take what you're given.
And I heard that you
were actually offered,
you turned down a million
dollar signing bonus
during that time. Right
before Piece Of You, right?
- Yeah, I was homeless.
I ended up living in my
car because I wouldn't
have sex with the boss.
And so I was living in my car,
and then my car got stolen
and I started gigging
to try and just get by.
And I ended up getting discovered
accidentally after a year.
And there's a bidding war
over me. It was crazy.
And I was offered a million
dollar signing bonus,
but I realized it was a loan. And I had to
give that money back through record sales.
And I wanted to make an honest record.
Like I made myself a promise
at the beginning of my career
that I would be a happy human
before I would be a musician.
- [Kelly] Amen.
- And that I would choose art over fame.
And that really helped me navigate.
And it's why I made decisions like that,
and it saved my career, that
record failed for over a year.
And they would have
dropped me unquestionably.
And the fact that I
turned that money down,
and I also took the biggest
back-end anybody had gotten.
So that once I started selling
records, I really made money.
- Yeah. I mean and that's the thing I tell
even like the artists on The
Voice that I work with now,
cause I'm from a singing
competition and I talk to them,
I'm like, look, I love
the, any door's a good door
as a singer, or artist, or writer.
However, you are. Any door's, a good door,
but what you do once you get through it,
and the character that you're,
you've got to live with that decision,
like for the rest of your life.
- Yeah! I think that's why
you're one of the only successful
artists to come out of
those singing shows,
because if singing was all it took,
there'd be a lot of famous
people from those shows.
It takes a lot of character,
a lot of grit, and work ethic,
and a lot of other things,
and not selling yourself
short, like as artists
we cannot want to be famous
more than we want to be
happy as humans, you know?
- Oh my gosh, you would make
an amazing coach on The Voice.
I'm just saying, I would pick you.
- Well, you know, I'm here.
- I would pick you. I was
like, and I think, you know,
I literally, it's so funny.
You took the words right out of my mouth.
I say it all the time. Like, look,
the show is about many different voices.
The main one obviously vocally
like impressing people,
moving people, but it's
also your character.
People watch the show, they see you,
they see your personality,
they buy into all of it,
you know? And so it's so true.
I agree with you on that.